- I'm not gonna go in a
closet with the lights out
or anything.
- What? This isn't Eyes Wide Shut.
(laughs)
Hi, I'm Kelsey, and this is my mom.
- Hi, I'm Kristy, Kelsey's mom.
- That's what I just said.
- Oh. Well, at least I know who I am.
- Today we're gonna get
handcuffed together for 24 hours.
- What? What, what, what?
- This is gonna be fun.
- Our relationship, I think, is a normal
relationship of a...
- What? That's it?
- No.
- It's normal?
We talk about sex and
butt stuff all the time.
- Well, isn't that normal?
- I think we have a
really good relationship.
(laughs)
I always say she's like, my best friend,
not really a mom.
- I'm a professional mother
with a professional daughter.
I can talk about anything.
You can call, well you
can't call me anytime.
I'm available from about 8:00 until 10.
- I think the hardest thing is gonna be
actually being around each other.
When we hang out we
always say that we have
a shelf life of three days.
- This could it.
This could be the breaking point.
- Give me your hand.
- Really? Right now, this very minute?
- Yeah.
- Wait, do I gotta do anything?
- It doesn't matter 'cause
I'm coming with you.
- Wait, wait, wait!
- How do I take my watch off?
- You gonna do my side?
- I kind of feel like, trapped.
- You carried me for nine months.
- Would you make the
chain a little bit longer?
- No, they're handcuffs.
I cuffed you mother fucker.
- Oh!
God help us.
- Now we gotta go.
- All right.
- Are you ready to do this?
- Let's go.
- I need to grab the wheel.
- Oh.
She talked me into
getting microblading done,
so they're gonna cut a bunch of slices
in our eyebrows, and then
pour dye in those slices.
- You coulda just said we're
going to get microbladed.
- Oh.
- You gotta put
your seatbelt on.
- Well, if I have to get
strapped in with one more thing,
this is what that claustrophobic
thing is all about.
- This is a lot of fun, gals.
- I feel like everyone thinks
being chained to their mom
would be like, oh, a little sweet thing,
like she'd do everything for
you, and scratch your back,
where it's like, being
chained to her is just like
being in a conference call all day.
- Well you might learn something.
- We have given up on driving.
So we finally decided to get an Uber.
She doesn't like hanging out with me.
- (laughs) Well, in doses.
- Mom's gonna talk to her
assistant and tell her
what we're doing today.
- Hey, well listen, I
just wanted to make sure
you got the last contract that
I was working on last night.
- Okay, we made it to the grove.
Now we just have to go to
Vince and exchange my shoes.
Okay. Now you gotta stand up with me.
- So cute!
Oh!
- Do you wanna see those ones?
(mumbles)
- This is how I'm trying on my jacket.
(laughter)
- I think that looks really nice.
- Your arm (mumbles)
I got you unzipped, but now how do we...
- Okay, now I gotta get my strap off.
- I think I...
- Can you
crawl through my hole?
- No.
(water running)
Don't get my eyebrows.
- Oh, oh.
- Not ideal.
Here's the thing; it's like
you seen me naked many times.
It's not like we have
any shame of being naked
around each other.
It's just not ideal.
- I'm not coming in there either.
- Just put your hand in here.
How am I supposed to shave my legs?
- Well, why do you gotta
shave your legs for?
You're just going to bed.
- That's a good point.
It's not like I'm gonna get
laid in the next 24 hours
being handcuffed to you.
- Well.
- Well we realized that showering was way
too fucking hard, so
instead of mom showering
we found a pretty good alternative.
- Well, don't get that on my eyebrows.
- Dry shampoo instead.
It's like a shower.
- In my mouth.
- Every night before I go to bed you know
that I like to do yoga, like, a little bit
of light stretching and
meditation to wind down
for the day.
But this is not very zen.
Let's do some stretching.
Pull the neck to the side.
- Good. You pull mine and I'll pull yours.
- What? That makes no sense.
- Then you pull...
- What?
Don't knee me in the face.
- Spread your legs.
(hums)
Is there one where we can
put our backs together?
Back.
- What is this doing exactly?
- Ah. Bonding.
- It's 9:30.
I'm ready to lay down
and turn off the lights
and she is still fucking negotiating.
- But they have to anything on my turf:
plumbing, weeding, cooling.
- Finally now, she can sleep,
but I can't fucking sleep.
My mom gets up at 7:00 a.m., so I guess
I'm getting up at 7:00 a.m..
- It's time to get back to work.
- I'm chained. Ball and chained.
Do you have any advice for us to last
these last couple of insane hours?
- You know, we found that it was,
the most comfortable way to
make it not hurt your wrist
is to hold hands.
- I don't wanna hold your hand.
- What?
- That's not very nice to
see you walk into my place.
This is arguably the least
hardest thing we've done.
This is actually quite easy to do.
For all you fans who wanna
see where Yugeet sleeps.
- Hey!
- You do this with your moms?
- No.
- No, my mom's not so much
into drag brunch.
Have you been to a drag show?
- Oh yeah. I been around.
- So brunch is nice 'cause we can get like
bottomless mimosas if you like.
(cheers)
- Have fun ladies!
- Ed,
- Hello.
- would you ever do this?
- I don't know.
- This fucking hurts and
she won't get off her phone.
I feel like an angry mom who's like,
put your phone down.
- You're the mom now.
- Get off your phone.
It's like we're married.
But my spouse doesn't wanna
be married to me.
- Yes, I like
younger, neurotic women.
(laughs)
- Some backup has arrived.
As long as we can still drink,
this is gonna be okay.
Do you feel like you learned
anything new about me?
- Not at all. I know who you are.
- Same.
And for us it's just showing
a different dichotomy
of what a mom and daughter
can be, and how...
- We're two strong women though.
Very strong women.
- Right. Yeah
And like, that's okay.
We're both very independent
self-reliant women,
but what this forced us
to do was to slow down
totally.
- Be mindful. Mindful.
Yeah.
- Be super mindful,
and see like, what the
other person needed.
It was less about us
connecting emotionally,
and more about us learning
how to have patience
and tolerance for one another.
(record scratch)
Now take these fucking handcuffs off.
♫ Freedom
- Take it off.
- I can't.
- Wait, mom.
- What?
(laughs)
Yay!
- I can breathe.
Love ya.
Say you love me.
- Oh, yeah. I love you too, honey.
- Fuck. I'm getting outta here.
I have no handcuffs attached.
(laughs)
I can leave.
- Yay!
(upbeat music)